talk about a Multiverse of Madness Sony
pictures animation sequel Spider-Man
across the spiderverse not only breaks
new ground in the superhero genre but it
also breaks the understanding of the
Marvel Multiverse at large a seemingly
established in Spider-Man no way home
all Marvel movies at least those in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and those
released by Sony Pictures coexist in the
same Multiverse with every iteration of
the titular web Slinger just to spell
away from one another while across the
spiderverse doesn't violate the
guidelines set in previous Marvel
Multiverse romps it does build upon them
in ways that could affect the mcu's
defining Multiverse project the Disney
plus series Loki Loki season 2 is set to
premiere on October 2023. in season 1
outlined how the Multiverse Works grows
and is maintained across all Marvel
properties it's mind-blowing first
season finale casts some doubt on the
stringency of these rules as The
Mastermind behind the multiversal
maintenance turns out to be an unstable
Kang variant known as he who remains
where Loki pulled the rug out from
audiences in terms of their
understanding of the Multiverse
spider-verse introduces new rules that
are seemingly unimpeachable especially
in regards to the film's defining Panic
Canon events a Canon event is a moment
in a spider person's lifetime that has
consistent across all variants in the
spider-verse and cannot be changed
without risking total Universal
destruction this includes tragedies like
the death of a loved one I looked at my
cool let me guess he died when this
concept is explained at the spider
Society headquarters the Hologram shows
an image that looks similar to Loki's
branching representation of the
Multiverse interestingly enough an
eerily similar concept is introduced in
the Disney plus animated series what if
referred to as absolute points the power
required to break an absolute point in
time is immense and nigh impossible to
obtain yeah no DOI the first absolute
Point delineated as such is the death of
Christine Palmer in the episode what if
Doctor Strange lost his heart instead of
his hands over the course of the story
viewers see that absolute points are
nearly impossible to change without some
sort of multiversal intervention when Dr
Strange Supreme manages to do just that
his world begins to dissolve into
Blackness and across the spider-verse
Miles Morales inadvertently shows fans
what a decaying Universe looks like when
he saves the life of the police captain
of paviter provocars Earth 5101 iri
all-consuming Blackness Bears a
resemblance to similar events in what if
and Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness this could mean that in every
Universe what audiences see is the
inter-universal apocalypse known as an
incursion what is an incursion take it
away Reed an incursion occurs when the
boundary between two universes erodes
and they Collide by violating the
boundaries between universes miles and
Doctor Strange unintentionally altered
Canon events or absolute points if you
will though the Newfound specificity is
small it creates guidelines that going
forward could change how heroes and
villains deal with Marvel universe's
newest overarching threat spider-verse
also presents a key that could save the
Fate to the entire Marvel Multiverse in
the near future you say a fate of the
Multiverse and my brain dies until
across the spiderverse there were only a
handful of beings capable of traversing
the Multiverse intentionally now there's
a possibly infinite number of spider
people that possess the ability to
travel the Multiverse and seemingly
prevent incursions a scene on Earth 5101
Miguel O'Hara and his team are able to
keep the Blackness at Bay by arriving on
the scene immediately this is a skill
that neither Doctor Strange nor Loki's
TVA have been able to pull off as the
second season of Loki continues to
explore and elaborate upon how the
Multiverse works it will likely come up
against the subject of incursions and
how they are caused it could lay the
groundwork for Loki to discover a way to
prevent incursions himself thus staving
off the inhabited messy aftermath of
King's meddling in the Multiverse it
would be a fitting end to the
character's story as he learns how to
maintain order without the
quasi-murderous ideologies of Miguel
O'Hara and he who remains instead of
pruning Loki could stimulate growth
big metaphor guy I love it makes you
sound super smart narratively a focus on
growth would be the polar opposite of
the infinity saga's ethos which
communicated that Victory demands
sacrifice as skillfully as this message
is conveyed it would be fitting for the
new era of the Marvel Multiverse to
usher in something different by
embracing the ability for comic book
stories to evolve Beyond reader's
wildest imaginations without all the
nihilism the perfect place to set up
this much needed shift would be in films
like across the spider-verse and TV
series like Loki which tells stories
about the wonders of expanding worlds
and the potential beauty of creative
evolution
thank you